tomemos la derivada del seno de
logaritmos natural de x cuadrada y como
vemos esta sería como una composición de
funciones por lo que el camino que
podríamos tomar para resolver esta
derivada sería llamar a una función seno
de x y luego obtener otra función de x
que sea igual al logaritmo natural de x
y finalmente f g h hdx de la función x
cuadrada entonces esto que acabamos de
escribir aquí sería exactamente la misma
cosa que tratar de tomar la derivada
respecto de x de dicha composición por
lo que sea la derivada respecto de x de
efe vg compuesta con un hd x y lo que
quiero hacer es como una especie de
construcción de como yo lo hago en mi
cabeza sin tener que escribir todo esto
de la regla de la cadena y su respectiva
anotación así que como la forma en la
que la estoy pensando hacer aquí es como
yo realmente lo veo en mi cabeza
donde la derivada de f que viene siendo
el seno sabemos que es el coseno y voy a
abrir aquí unos paréntesis es el coseno
de x pero en este caso no es xy no desde
lo que está compuesta dicha función como
habíamos dicho es una composición de
funciones aquí lo voy a poner del mismo
color para que se identifique entonces
la derivada del seno de esta composición
va a ser el coseno de dicha composición
y bueno aquí escribamos la x cuadrada
del mismo color amarillo para que no
vaya a surgir ningún tipo de confusiones
y bueno si esto lo puedes ver lo puedes
imaginar sería lo mismo que escribir f
prima de la composición pero hablando
como en términos de las funciones que
sería la derivada de f deje de hdx y
esto te puede servir para llevar una
orden de cómo fuiste o cómo vamos
realizando las cosas entonces en este
caso sería de cómo fuimos derivando efe
con lo que lleva adentro y en cierto
punto esto si llega a ser importante de
cómo vamos realizando esto porque aquí
vamos a notar ahora
producto de lo que se deriva de adentro
de la composición de la función entonces
en este caso sería la derivada del
logaritmo de x cuadrada del logro
natural de x cuadrada y como nosotros
podemos recordar esta derivada es 1
sobre la composición entonces en este
caso nos quedaría 1 sobre x cuadrada y
aquí abajo de igual manera como lo
hicimos anteriormente vamos a poner g
prima de la composición que en este caso
igual es la x cuadrada que pongo con
amarillo pero como estamos hablando en
términos de las funciones lo voy a
borrar y aquí vamos a poner la hd x
porque aquí estamos poniendo como los
términos de las funciones en cuanto a
las letras por así decirlo y acá vendría
también la multiplicación de la derivada
de hb x que en este caso es 2x y aquí se
multiplica igual por h prima de x en
cada una de la composición de funciones
que utilizando la regla de la cadena y
para hacer esto más claro lo que estoy
encerrando
por aquí vendría siendo lo mismo que
esto de acá abajo lo morado donde el
recuerdo de arriba sería la forma
concreta de la función y abajo la forma
abstracta y para este par también los
que estoy encerrando del color azul y
finalmente estos dos de por acá también
vendrían siendo lo mismo solamente que
una forma concreta y el otro de una
forma más abstracta lo que hemos hecho
es como simplificar las expresiones de
una forma que sea más claro ahora si él
realizó este producto si te das cuenta
abajo tengo una equis cuadrada y arriba
en el numerador tengo otra equis por lo
que podría decir que las voy a cancelar
sería la equis de arriba entonces ahora
al realizar bien el producto por acá
abajo lo voy a escribir vendría quedando
2x por el coseno de el logaritmo natural
de x cuadrado y esto ya tiene un aspecto
más sencillo directamente entonces en
otras palabras lo que hemos decidido es
que este es el seno respecto de algo y
que al derivar lo
como el coseno de ese algo donde la
derivada de este dicho algo a su vez
tiene una composición que fue la del
logaritmo de x cuadrada que también más
adelante derivamos y nos vino quedando
simplemente la 2x calaba de realizar
todo el producto de esta composición
como de tres funciones nos queda
simplemente 2 sobre x por el coseno de
logaritmos natural de x cuadrada y listo